how do you know anything how do I know
anything um I usually analyze like uh I
I think the basis for knowing things is
subject to uh evidence so basically when
I say I know that I'm like here right
it's not like I pulled out a bunch of
dictionaries and I'm like what is the
definition of here it's we it's a known
fact about the world that people exist
and I'm exp the cons huh because we can
see that we can observe how do you know
that what you're seeing is real and not
just a hallucination that's a big
question I don't think you truly can
know that I think I can know with you're
very confident in your opinions I think
but you just said you're not confident
that I'm also confident in the things
that I don't know I think it's
confidence being able to say when you
don't know a thing I think that but what
you've just said is you don't know for
certain that you know anything at all
yeah I don't think you can know anything
for certain I'm I'm reasonably certain
that you cannot know anything everything
for certain well of course not but but
but I'm not asking if you can know
everything I'm asking you can know
anything